yeah
so yeah thanks so thanks for coming I'm
Tony my facebook a research for this
year it's a based in Santa stop judging
stem for effort so this is joint work
based on Sudan based on short work with
Ron go and Jason reaches and he Knollys
so for some of the audience you may
notice that like the first of three
slides actually I borrowed from the
previous talk I gave here at the same
you know in the same program that can
involve the previous workshop so but the
rest of talk is different right so so
let me start by talking a bit about what
I see is there some new possible
interfaces between users optimizers in
the context of machine learning so so
typically you know when we talk about
optimization you know the interface that
will help with the users is that the
user the users and the optimization
researchers are functional at and
optimization researchers you know just
have to figure out how to solve it
basically so you can use simple
algorithms like winning descent or local
search algorithms for this great case
all we could use for example convex
fixation if the problem is not comebacks
and use wrongly but at the end of the
day we always have to send back a
solution to the users and it doesn't
really matter how we solve it we need to
solve give back our solution and the
users only have to check whether the
solution is good or not and the context
machine learning you know because so we
want to you know sometimes they'll
consider balance between the
optimization and the statistics so
sometimes these interfaces are you know
augmentative is you know most your
properties of the function for example
we can say the function is a sum of
functions which is very typical in
machine learning and setting and maybe
we can also have other properties of a
function like the function is convex
smooth strongly convex you know oh we
have good condition number so and so
forth and still the optimization
researches in to figure out how to solve
it and now we have a set of functions
maybe he's you know some advanced
version of stochastic eccentric saga as
TCS vrg and more so and so forth so and
however anyway you have to send back to
the solution to the to the user and a
user when I have to check whether the
solution is good or not so I'd like to
propose some other possible
interfaces in a little bit more flexible
interfaces between users and of
optimization researchers like like this
so the user receptor function to the
optimization researcher and its function
is non convex you know in most of the
talk because I think that this talk like
oh you know I'm thinking mostly about
non convex functions and it may be the
first question that optimization
researchers can ask is whether this
function is easy or not there might be
multiple ways to interpret it interpret
this question in it could be this
question could be interpreted as whether
this function is fundamentally easy
whether we can have done along with time
algorithm or we could interpreters
whether we have a reasonably practical
price our algorithm for it or we could
even interpreters whether the trivial
stuff has to be nice and solve it and
and if the answer is no then maybe we
can go back and ask okay this function
is too hard can you change the change
the function and in typical settings
this is kind of not not doable because
you know the function itself is what
really occur as the user but for machine
learning this is somewhat to some extent
a little bit flexible so we can say okay
let me try a new model and on a new loss
and this is a typo last time and but
they have found that actually makes some
sense so in some of the audience told me
so I keep it because we're talking
without cat anyway so okay so and
suppose we figure out a new model new
function and okay so I guess this is not
quite own for this audience but you know
machine learning we have a model and we
in supervised learning we map X to Y and
the model is a parametric function G
theta and also we can choose the loss
function in many times so so loss
function model are kind of the flexible
part of it and then we find a new
function f prime and we send it to
opposition researchers and maybe this
time it's easy and we can use use the
trivial algorithm store custom instance
or with some momentum you turn your
program rate so and so forth so and and
then we just new send the solution back
and often we don't have to care about
rounding because this new function f
prime good solution for this F prime F
prime is some surprises and you know of
we have to care about other things but
but in terms of solution itself for
tuning we don't have to care about
anything we don't have to run and
actually this is what happens in deep
learning communities and this is how
people make progress for optimization so
and these are you know very important
progresses that people made the
optimizations like a gradual the
introduced introduction of values
significant speed up the optimization
compared to sigmoid over permutation is
another powerful technique you make the
pot bit more bigger and bigger sometimes
the model is even bigger than the number
of examples and and it make the twinning
faster and the patronization is another
way to you normalize the model in some
way so that the corners are kind of you
know normalize the cross across samples
and receive a network is on a way to
change the model so all of these don't
really change the reputation of power of
the model they really change the
optimization landscape so so it sounds
like there is a possible paradigm for
optimization theory in learning so you
are an it so they're kind of three steps
so you identify a family of four
checkbook functions and the kind of the
feasible set is the set of functions to
be all o coming about approximately
global minimum and then we can write
another question is whether we can
decide whether a function below this
family currently we don't have that much
techniques so one of the popular
technique is kind of use decent
combination of linear algebra and
probability
so basically way all there are recent
works that try to see whether we can use
res formula to count how many a local
minimum of an in function has and in
this talk I'm mostly focusing on the
third bullet here so whether we can use
a new objective and function is that
approval in the time they have there are
some recent progresses in simplified
settings we don't know too much about it
so with more is heart and burn rate or
we have tried to understand whether we
parameterize the overpronation model can
work better in the linearized the
setting for you know in linearize the
network setting and Carman solved
un-comment
leon it all started
memorized models and proof that over
commercial swallows have better
optimization escape so and and this in
this talk I'm going to talk about the
the last one where we design new
objective functions for for learning
well-hidden neural network and of course
just note besides so we also need care
about John's Asia era but not in this
talk alright so now let's talk about a
problem that we are going to study so we
have a very very simple setting so
assume the data x and y axis the input Y
is the label satisfy some it is
generated by some ground choose network
so this network is just well hidden
layer so two matrices so we apply B we
multiply B star with ax so okay
pictorially so we have a vector ax in D
dimension we multiply matrix B star we
get some random variable we put it
through some long arrow T Sigma so Sigma
is you know you can think that's regular
sigmoid and you apply it and Chu element
wise to B star X we get a vector and you
apply a star transpose and you get a
number Y and you add some noise so the
noise is not quite important for this
talk so it's kinda a big assumption is
that we assume the data from constant
description this is a big assumption but
that's um that's what that's the only
thing we can do and our goal is to learn
a function that predicts y given x how
do we have show that we can also recover
the parameter is P star in a star all
right
so and for most of the salkinds just
think of Sigma x value the max of X and
0 and the fault of experiments in the
talk but the theory also works for other
activation functions so let's start by
thinking about the street power
objective because we have you know
additive noise then it makes sense to
use some l2 loss so our prediction is
just the same as you know our parametric
model is just a signal our assumption so
we have B and a these are variables so
we just use the same shape a star and B
star and so this is our prediction
our loss it's just the expected squared
loss this is the population loss all
right so I guess so
I'm just for personal curiosity by show
of hands how many of you think this loss
function can work
okay like I can recover the parameter a
star and B star a reasonable amount of
time let's say you have an infinite
number of time even amount of time and
you start casting beans sorry there's
this oh well your poster for question
but but anyway so I think you know I
don't ask this because it seems that in
the writing committee you know including
me I don't believe that this kind can be
done but but most of the you know at
least Oh
some of the researchers that talk with
you know doing applied research they do
believe that this kind now work but the
the answer is that it's not going to
work in the following size so if you
look at the population risky so I'm not
going to work I'm just meaning that I
use sarcasm in Santa Ana learning rate
at the case during rage carefully and
and and the y axis here is the
population risk so faculty I mean the
expected population rates because I take
fresh samples to ask me the population
risk and the wax is the number of
iterations so so here is the setting so
the dimension is 50 and a star is a 1
vector and we assume it is known so we
don't have to even Laurent we only need
to enter into the matrix B and the B
star is identity matrix 50 by 50 so this
is probably the best matrix you can hope
for
and you can see the noise is 0 and we
use fresh samples at every iteration
there's no authorization issue which is
to do pure store customers and with
fresh samples and and so that means so
because the noise is 0 which means that
the global minima
the global minimum should have a
population of X 0 and we can see that so
we cannot get it down to 0 and you can
also try to see whether the parameters
we'll learn is is correct or not
right so the parameter so how do we
compare the parameter B always the B
star right so so what we do is that you
know ideally want to have make sure we
want B to be a permutation of B star so
we can measure the distance between b
and b star by finding the bad
the permutation but here we just use a
surrogate loss just for computational
purpose so so here the loss presenting
here is basically a casting for us if a
row or column of B is absent far away
from the natural basis infinite norm
then the error is absolute so and we can
see that the error plateaus at point one
basically means that there's always a
row or column that is point one away
from one of the perm any of the
permutation of P star we are using
stochastic extent and we decrease the
learning rate like a week you know
learning Rachel Arabic carefully so we
try to Decatur the rate after well until
it plateaus I think so yeah we do have
identifiability you can see in the you
know I said the algorithm results we
have later or show that
all right so some of the really work so
there are works that show that if you
don't the filters are non-overlapping if
there goes of B stars have these joints
of course then on the landscape that
straightforward object if that the shot
will work and and you enjoy and the
onion also showed that in irritation
insufficient if the extradition is
sufficient close to B star inspection or
then it's gonna work and in our case the
bad local minima is very far from B star
inspection or by the way but pretty
close in if they ignore and they also
kernel based method and they also pick
ten thirty competition methods followed
by local improvement algorithms so on
this will give a polynomial time
algorithm for the setting that I'm
talking about so what we are our
contribution is it's not really to
propose a new polynomial time algorithm
it's more about understanding the
landscape and think about how to change
the orbit function and well the
empirical solution is that you use over
commercialization for example if the the
true dimension is fifty the hidden barb
the dimension of helium vector hidden
variables is fifteen and you can you can
over parameterize the inner tuning by a
factor of two for example and then the
arrow will becomes much will become much
smaller all right
so and in this talk we're trying to you
know design new lost model and loss
functions but for the next slide let me
just step back a little bit to
understand the switch power luggage
functions that defined before a little
better so we're going to keep analytical
formula for the object function that we
defined the IO to loss so recall this is
the setting we have a network as a
ground truth and we consider out to loss
so here is the theorem so suppose the
rows of P are unit vectors which is
reasonable assumption and axes from
spherical Gaussian and then we have this
gigantic formula for the population risk
and let me parse this for you let's let
me first explain on the tation so the BI
is other rows or from B and the BI stars
are the rows of P B star okay that's
what this bi star VIP I star here and I
is the corner of the vector a and Sigma
hat is the hermit coefficient of Sigma
the activation function Sigma so the
definition is that you have
is the normalized hermite polynomial and
Sigma hat K is just the inner product
between Sigma and HK so for more
photographers that really matter so the
only thing we know is that Sigma hat K
ism so they are unknown numbers so they
are [ __ ] there are properties of the
occupation function and they decay
reasonably fast not very fast actually
all right so so let me parse this a bit
more so if you look at this each term
for each K this square for bingham
square this is actually doing or 1030
conversation so we have here AI star and
P I start these are ground choose so
these are kind of constant so we have a
sum of each of these I I start bi starts
to test a power K this is a rank one
tensor in no other is the other carry
back one tester so the sum is a rock ant
answer I miss the dimension of the
number of rows of P so I think so I miss
the number of rows so and so basically
we are trying to decompose this rock and
out there K tensor by you know by our
variables and so it show of themselves
the ten that compensation power and so
well published now hope to use this
formula is that maybe because we nest
antacid composition better maybe we can
understand each term here better and so
that we can kind of understand the some
of them in some way but unfortunately
the you know if you don't do anything
this or a brake function is not going to
be good enough so but still let's look
at each term just to get a little bit
intuition so f 0 this is just the sum of
AI star - some of my eye so we are
trying to match the sum of AI and f1 is
the sum of AI star ei star minus the sum
of AI bi you clean norm square so we are
trying to make sure that the linear
combination of P I is the same as the
ink on the combination of VI stark and
similarly I have to is trying to match
the second moment and I for is trying to
match the weighted fourth moment so if
you look at this term so in some sense
this is the kind of trade off so the
first one is a convex but it's not
enough for ended viability the second
one it's not comebacks in both a and B
but it doesn't have a super local
minimum because it's kind of a culture
take and and but it's also not enough
for added Bertie because there we only
need to match the combination of PS and
a third one we I strongly contact with
this also has no experience local minima
but I don't think there's a existent
proof I don't know how to prove it as
well but it doesn't sound super hard and
it's not identifiable as well because
you know there's a rotational invariance
in the bi so you can rotate BIA in a way
so that you can match the second moment
without the recovering Pai star but the
first one no there's a little
problematic because there exist about
zero point zero you know is a very bad
to the point because the other higher
order derivatives vanishes also the
lower all the derivative Spanish is and
but it's not an enviable so if you are
given the tensor sum of a I star P I
star x r4 you can recover the a SMPS and
they're reasonable conditions right so
so hopefully this is a trade-off between
the landscape and a defi ability so
that's kind of one of the hope that we
had before and the answer is to some
extent with there is a there's a there's
a way to make this work and which I will
show in the next slide so so so here is
a it's a slightly different idea so what
we do is now we change the model ourself
so now in the in the learning we make we
use a different activation function
camera even though the data are still
from the same model so what is karma our
cheese come on your moment but still but
but let's just catch the population risk
as we have done before so now the
formula changes a little bit because we
use a different activation camera in
each inning and now we have come a hot K
here and Sigma hotkey there so recall
that if you take comma high to be the
same I say my heightened you're going to
put this Sigma hat K in front and you
get Sigma hat K square so this is the
more s the same formula and so what are
we going to do is we're going to choose
gamma such that gamma hat 2 is equals to
Sigma a 2 and gamma hat 4 is equals to
Sigma hat for
and all of the gamma other gamma had K
we're going to choose them to be zero so
we are free to choose this because this
is the first place there's a one-to-one
mapping between gamma and gamma hat and
now the what happens is that if you look
at any term except the second term and
the first term then because gamma hat is
zero then this gigantic thing is just
going to be a constant because
everything is a fixed a star is fixed be
a star is fixed and there's no variable
so basically what you have is that we
keep all of the terms except the second
term and the fourth term we get Sigma
hat square times f2 plus sigma hat or
four square times F 4 plus a constant so
expected a we are removing all of the
style of the terms that just seems to be
a little bit difficult and when we have
the second term in the foster and hope
is that you know this will be easier
this landscape will be better because we
don't have the interaction of the
haroldo term in the lower the first term
and maybe it's easier to analyze so the
good news is that the empirical it works
but the bad news is that still we don't
know how to analyze it so the quick
question so the third term are just
natural advantages because the ok
because we are mostly thinking about
value and for relu the third term had 0
sigma hats are 3 is 0 yeah but for other
things you can publish with the searcher
it's not quite important so so here is
the empirical results so if you do this
you trim with some gamma and the data is
from Sigma and you can see that maybe
the most important thing here you know
the left hand side I take F gamma minus
the global minimum because not the
global minima is not zero anymore and it
converts to the global minimum and in
terms of parameter error actually the
same way as I described before you have
some heuristic way to match the the the
final best permutation and you measure
the error and it does converge to 0 so
the same setting as before
so any questions so far so like I guess
you have five minutes so yes so let's
briefly discuss about them the proof of
put-down comebacks algorithms I'm mostly
rotation with parsley or theorization so
I still care about the approval
algorithms so how do we do that so let's
take a step back to think a little bit
about what we did with the with the
previous two cases so in some sense the
key lemma that we were using to prove
those some pop to get the analytical
formula for the population loss was
something like this so you take the
expectation of the data Y x times some
you know function of X and B so and and
this expectation have analytical formula
just because you know HK is the the
hermite polynomial and the access
coefficient so you have some nice
properties P about them so and you get
something like this is exactly two
doesn't really matter so but the thing
is that we have our sum or from some
weighted sum of some power of inner
product can be a star and PJ PJ star bi
and you can extend this formula a little
bit and get something like you know this
doesn't help you power for any
polynomial here if you respect place the
eighth power of a polynomial you can you
can find another function V P so that
this formula is true so in some sense
what I'm saying is that if you have
something like this in mind if you want
to optimize this then you can ask me at
least this objective function
you know this function depends on V star
so you have to ask me from the data and
you can ask me to using the samples so
and you can also make this more
complicated saying you have a two
variables here and and there is a
polynomial for the inner part of beans
and VJ star and bi and PJ star and PK
and you can still ask MIT which we saw
from the samples so you know so
basically that the catch is that we have
some kind of family of functions and we
know how to ask me to using the samples
and we want to choose one function that
does the job so so this is the function
that we finally choose a sort of a
complicated
exactly you know formula doesn't really
imagine for this talk you know because I
don't really have time to get into
details so so this is some degree you
know kind of degree 4 polynomial via the
variable B and is you know this is some
polynomial of BI start times B gmvi
start times B K and we also I some term
here to make to make things work you
know so and there's also a constraint
that the BI is what so maybe before
passing this in more detail so then let
me just don't tell the theorem so we
assume that AI star is larger than 0
this is a crucial assumption for the
theorem to work and bi star the B star
is of thought no but but this is not
crucial we can you know make a term or
relax that assumption so and so we have
several things about this function so G
B as we discuss the you know this can be
asked me to bear samples that's kind of
what we discussed in the previous right
so you can design some function that
only depends on a variable and a data so
that the inner product of that function
with Y is GB and and also a global
minimum of G is equals to B star up to
permutation and scaling of the logs so
this can be seen more or less from here
so basically the only way to make this
small is to choose B to be a permutation
of B star because if that's the case
then this will this first term will be 0
because psrp J and P I start B K one of
them has to be 0 if J is not equals to K
and and bi and B is just a permutation
of BI be a DJ is a permutation of piece
VJ star then this has to be 0 and an all
the local minima of G are global minima
and this is much more technical to proof
but in some sense they are knows not so
much too much magic here because the
subject function is inspired by one of
the previous work by room go at all
which prove the case when mu is 0 and AI
stars are all one so we mostly just
simplified proof a little bit and the
next
it's a more complete version because we
have the AI star ISM so we don't want to
assume a estar squeal one so but in
sometimes they are not you know this is
most techno party of the paper but they
are not too much new things provided
here so that the profile more or less
standard it's a little involved but you
know you how do you prove all of coming
up on global what you do is you compute
you you know who try to compute all the
set of points and all the critical
points and at least you get some
properties of the critical points and
then you plug in those properties into
the Hacienda see which one can survive
and and you get all our local minima and
there happens to be global minimum so
and this can be extended to non singular
B stars but the constraint is the
limitation is that we can only deal with
the case when P star is um you know maps
to from higher dimension to lower
dimension which means that the hidden
variable dimension has to be lower than
a data to mention alright so I'm just
and now it starts to work you know with
the theorem and also it works
empirically so I think the most
important thing is the right-hand side
so the in the parameter space we can see
that the arrow converges to zero
you know with a little bit hesitation
guys okay so what happens here is that
term oh you have to break all ties in
some way so that in this metric you can
go up because you have to break ties in
some way so you know so the metric that
we are using is that we want to look at
them whether each row or each column is
close to an actual basis but in a
training what happens is that some of
the column has to really have to really
be very close to zero first and then
kind of close to Union from first and
then go to one of the natural basis
that's probably what happens all right
so and one of the caveat about the
experiment is that it requires a much
larger batch size and training data sets
so part of reason I think is that we
kill too much information by the kind of
like killing all of us high order terms
and those are how the terms do
for some useful information but we are
we're not using them so the last slide
so as a conclusion so we design new
models and objectives so what to do
design new models and practice with good
landscape properties and this paper
takes well the first step for simplified
networks and some open questions as I
mentioned before so sample efficiency is
of the job back or from of this idea so
we need more samples to to new artwork
compared to the suite forward objective
even though it's to develop looked at in
to converge to a perfect solution but it
does require much less than samples and
the best empirical way to do it seems to
be that use value we see use absolute
value for chaining relu basically what
this corresponds to is that you don't
kill all of those high order terms but
you only queue the first term so f1 so
you have a sum of five K's and you may
remove f1 and then activation function
becomes real and and this is the most
simple efficient way that we found
empirically but maybe there are better
ways and of course can we do beyond
Gaussian inputs our current technique
cannot do that but maybe some of the
related techniques can be useful and
another question is whether we can
understand overcome a transition which
is another way to simply fix them fixed
make their experimental mixer experiment
work and finally I guess so we are also
looking for more techniques for
analyzing optimization escape and some
of them you know typical here is that we
don't know how to analyze the
optimization escape so that we have to
suite for a different objective that can
be analyzable
thank you
just a quick question
this would essentially use you know the
input distribution how robust ceases if
you pull it efficiently disappear oh no
mm if this means don't caution so if
it's close to gosh so Archer
yeah I'm even if you see I we didn't try
to empirically and I suspect that so
some of so like we have I discussed like
three ways to do it why is the way that
doesn't work and the other ways that it
works but we don't know how to prove I
think that one probably is reasonably
robust to two perturbations in the input
and the last one that we can analyze
probably not very robust oh and it
should be you're busted a little bit but
not very well we thought about a little
bit I think there are some technical
issues with doing that but I'm not
saying it's impossible we didn't try
very hard
yeah whatever the distribution you put
into landscape should be the same but
your techniques won't work but it
doesn't mean it's not gonna be true that
that's part of the hope I don't know
whether that's you know I think it
should be the case of you know to some
extent yeah but our analysis techniques
at least for now is very heavily using
the Gaussian input we hope that they can
be yes
yeah
okay thanks
[Applause]